vamos a encontrar la configuración
electrónica del níquel que se encuentra
aquí tiene 28 electrones y vamos a
encontrar las capas en las que se
encuentran estos electrones la forma en
que aprendimos a hacerlo es que bueno si
este es el bloque ese y recordemos que
de hecho el helio pertenece a esta parte
cuando hablamos de orbitales en el
bloque s
este es el bloque de y este es el bloque
p así que comenzamos con los electrones
de menor energía y podemos encontrarlos
hacia adelante o hacia atrás si queremos
encontrarlos hacia adelante lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es ver que los
primeros dos electrones van en 1 s 2
así que escribimos aquí en níquel
llenamos primero 1s 2 aquí van 2
electrones y luego pasamos a 2s 2 y
recordemos que este 2 indica el número
de electrones que se encuentran en esa
sub capa o en ese orbital y después
vamos a tener a al bloque p que es 2 p 6
ya llenamos todos estos de aquí y vamos
a ver que ya tenemos ubicados a 10
electrones ahora en la tercera capa
llegamos a 3s 2 recuerden que estamos
trabajando con el níquel así que tenemos
que llenar 3s 2 y después en la tercera
capa llenamos 3 p 6 y estamos en el
tercer periodo y ahora pasamos a la
cuarta capa que la voy a hacer en otro
color así que aquí tenemos 4 s 2 y ahora
nos encontramos en el bloque de y de
aquí vamos a llenar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 en
este bloque de así que van a ser 8
electrones en el bloque d pero recuerden
que no va a ser 4 de 8 tenemos que
regresar para llenar la tercera capa por
lo que será 3 de 8 llenamos 3 de 8 aquí
y ese es el orden para poner los
electrones que están en un estado de
energía abajo primero y llegar hasta los
electrones que se encuentran en un
estado de energía alto pero noten que
los electrones que se encuentran en el
estado más alto de energía estos que
están en de que llegamos al final es
se fueron a la tercera capa recordamos
que cuando llenamos el bloque de tomamos
la capa en la que nos encontramos y le
restamos un 1 estamos en el cuarto
periodo de la tabla periódica y a éste
le restamos 1 así que este es 4 menos 1
por lo que esa es la configuración
electrónica del níquel y recuerden que
si vamos a tomar en cuenta los
electrones de valencia tenemos que ver
cuáles son los electrones que se
encuentran en la capa más externa y
tenemos que considerar a estos esos son
los electrones que van a reaccionar
aunque estos otros se encuentran en un
estado de energía mayor y éstos tienen
una mayor probabilidad de reaccionar ya
que son los que se encuentran más
alejados del núcleo comparados con estos
otros de aquí otra forma de encontrar la
configuración electrónica y esto se ve
en algunas clases de química aunque a mí
personalmente me gusta la forma en la
que lo hemos hecho ya que estamos
trabajando directamente con la tabla
periódica y nos estamos familiarizando
con ella y eso es importante ya que nos
va a dar una intuición sobre los
elementos que hay aquí y cómo reaccionan
entre ellos pero podemos decir que el
níquel tiene 28 electrones
bueno si es neutro tiene 28 electrones
si es neutro ya que este es el mismo
número de protones recordemos que este
28 nos dice cuál es el número de
protones que tiene este átomo si este es
el número de protones y estamos
suponiendo que es un átomo neutro tendrá
el mismo número de electrones y esto no
siempre va a ser el caso pero cuando
hacemos la configuración electrónica
tiene este hacer el caso así que decimos
es el níquel que tiene un número atómico
de 28 podemos encontrar la configuración
electrónica de esta otra forma podemos
escribir las capas de energía 1 2 3 4 y
aquí arriba escribimos s&p de una vamos
a llegar hasta efe pero lo podemos
escribir podemos seguir escribiendo efe
gh y los demás que siguen lo que va a
suceder es que voy a llenar este primero
después voy a llenar este otro y después
este otro después este y después éste lo
que estoy dibujando aquí son las capas
que existen en cada periodo lo que estoy
escribiendo ahorita no es el orden en
cómo se llenan solo soy
mostrando cuál es capaz existen tenemos
una sub capa 3d pero no hay una sub capa
efe hay una sub capa 4 f permítanme
dibujar líneas para separar esto la
forma en la que se llenan es que hacemos
estas diagonales llenamos esta capa s
así llenamos esta otra así ponemos esta
diagonal hacia abajo y esta otra
diagonal va así esta otra va así y sólo
debemos saber que sólo caben dos en ese
6 en p y en este caso 10 en d y veremos
efe en el futuro pero ahorita no nos
vamos a preocupar por esto de hecho si
ustedes ven el bloque f en una tabla
periódica sabrán cuántos electrones
caben en efe y la llenamos en este orden
primero decimos bueno para el níquel 28
electrones primero lleno este 1s 2 aquí
no tenemos 1 p así que paso a 2s 2
luego voy a arriba de esta diagonal me
dirijo hacia abajo y me encuentro con la
p2p 6 y tenemos que llevar la cuenta de
cuántos electrones estamos colocando en
este caso llevamos 10 así que usamos
este la flecha nos dice que pasemos aquí
abajo así que ahora llenaremos la
tercera capa de energía 3s 2 y luego
pasamos a seguimos la flecha nos indica
3 p 6 y lo siguiente que llenamos es 4 s
2 ahora llegamos a 4 ese 2 cual es lo
que sigue bueno regresamos a esta
diagonal bueno vamos al inicio de esta
diagonal y llenamos 3 de cuantos
electrones nos falta colocar bueno si
estamos en 3d ya hemos colocado dos más
dos es 46 es 10 10 más 2 es 12 + 6 son
18 aquí son 20 ya hemos colocado 20 nos
falta colocar 8 electrones más para
configurar y la sub capa 3d puede
albergar a los 8 que nos faltan así que
tenemos 3 de 8 y tenemos la misma
configuración que encontramos con el
primer método y como les comentaba a mí
me gusta este primer método porque
estamos usando la tabla periódica todo
el tiempo lo que era que nos
familiaricemos con los elementos y
también no tenemos que estar recordando
cuántos electrones ya he usado en lo que
he configurado y escribir este diagrama
elaborado en cambio aquí sólo usamos la
tabla periódica y lo importante es que
también podemos llenarla al revés con
este diagrama no hay una forma en la que
yo pueda saber de antemano en dónde se
ubicarán los electrones con más energía
o cuál será la capa de energía más
externa sin haber desarrollado todo este
proceso pero conocemos este método yo
puedo decir de inmediato que si me está
interesando conocer al elemento zr este
de aquí puedo hacer todo el ejercicio de
encontrar la configuración electrónica
completa para este elemento pero
normalmente la capa más alta o la que
tiene a los electrones más altos es la
capa que va a importar más así que
podemos decir que estoy llenando
recuerden que cuando estamos en el
bloque d tenemos que regresar un periodo
antes del que nos encontremos así que
esto es cuatro dedos ya que
periodo de 5 decimos que esto es 4 de 2
y antes de esto llenamos los electrones
5 s 2 y podemos seguir yendo hacia atrás
que antes llenamos 4 p 6 y antes de esto
llenamos 10 en el bloque de de aquí pero
como está en el cuarto periodo le voy a
restar 1 por lo que va a ser 3 de 10
después tenemos 4 ese 2 que me estoy
quedando sin espacio aquí lo tuve que
escribir aquí arriba que bueno aquí ya
tengo todo desordenado voy a escribirlo
por acá tenemos 4 dedos que son estos
dos de acá tenemos 5 ese 2 luego tenemos
4 p 6 que está para acá y ahora tenemos
tres de 10 recordemos que es 4 menos 13
de 10 y después tenemos 4 ese 2 y
seguimos retrocediendo así lo bueno de
retroceder es que de inmediato se puede
saber cuáles son los electrones que se
encuentran en la capa de energía más
alta bueno tengo este 5 que es la capa
de energía en donde me encuentro y estos
dos que acabo de llegar aquí son los
electrones que se encuentran en la capa
más alta de energía
no son los electrones de más alta
energía estos otros son los que tienen
una mayor probabilidad de reaccionar ya
que se encuentran más lejos del núcleo
así que estos son los que van a
reaccionar y son los que nos van a
interesar para la mayoría de los
propósitos en química y un punto aquí
que no se menciona siempre es que nos
gusta pensar que los electrones están
llenando estas capas pero una vez que
tenemos un átomo lleno de electrones no
se van a comportar de una manera muy
ordenada
van a estar saltando entre los orbitales
se van a estar mezclando y eran toda
clase de cosas locas e impredecibles
pero este método es lo que nos permite
al menos tener una idea de lo que sucede
con los electrones que generalmente
tienden a reaccionar o comportarse de la
manera que indican estos orbitales que
indican estos estados pero el punto
principal aquí es enseñarles cómo hacer
una configuración electrónica ya que
esto nos va a ser muy útil para conocer
más adelante cómo es que las cosas
interaccionan y lo que es
particularmente útil de saber es cuáles
son los electrones que se encuentran en
la capa
externa o los electrones de valencia